we always love your insight because it
gets so deep on you know even what's
going on in bachelor nation now I know
you wait a little bit in on the Madison
Peter stuff Madison also going on Peter
Weber season of The Bachelor as a virgin
I wanted to save myself a marriage do
you think she should have shared that
with him sooner handled that reveal
differently at all I mean if that was
her choice to hold off I think that she
saw what probably happened to me with it
becoming my sole storyline and maybe
that's why she hesitated and we maybe
why she waited you can't fault anybody
for handling a situation the way that
they want to handle it especially you
have to keep in mind like that's her
life this is her life and this is
something that she's gonna deal with
forever now and same with me so it's
like you can't fault anybody for
handling a certain situation her way and
I respect you a lot of people do a lot
of people did critique her for it yeah
yeah I don't I don't fault her one way
or another I mean I feel like as open as
Peter was that just wasn't the case for
me to do and I mean I don't know yeah
should Peter have done anything
differently I know you you made a couple
of comments like maybe he just kind of
got lost in it all I think I just would
have loved to see Peter stand up for
himself more and put his foot down and
I'm not only saying stand up to some of
the women on his season but even with
production and things going on behind
the scenes like just I would have loved
to for peer to be like listen guys like
this is what I want this is what we need
to figure out we need to get this done I
feel like he was so confused and sort of
involved in this mass chaos everyone
that knows him knows that it's it's not
you know it's not gonna work I didn't
watch but like that was what I was
getting from Twitter I mean you don't
have to watch the show anymore it's so
big that Twitter recaps it for you I
watched your obviously your roses
rose' and you hear like what's going on
I mean chase rice and Kelly like that
doesn't just happen like that was that
was setup and I mean think that you just
want to shake them and be like dude take
back control this is your story you are
going to be Peter after this you're not
going to be the bachelor forever so if
you want a healthy strong relationship
after this you were gonna have to fight
for it and I think that's so more so
what I would of wanted to see from him
is just some certainty one way or
another just being like listen I need
this I at least I don't know if I'm
gonna find it here but at least this is
what I need and this is what I'm gonna
fight for
[Music]